man barely made it out of that one how
exactly did you stop thanos the mad
titan from decimating half of the
universe oh no i'm not big enough
t'challa here showed me there was more
than one way to reallocate
you
oh my god this is bad news
there oh he got the parked outside
[Music]
[Applause]
this episode was great i love this
welcome back to new rockstars marvel
studios what if episode 2 asks what if
t'challa became star-lord and then
answers well thanos would be everyone's
best buddy
this is inside marvel it's our after
show for marvel's what if on disney plus
i'm eric voss now episode two was filled
with easter eggs i'm gonna break down in
the next video coming up on the channel
but right now i'm here reacting to this
episode with mt how you doing mt dude
i'm feeling good like seeing nice thanos
just kicking it with everybody like it's
it blew my mind i love it i freaking
love
this yeah i kept waiting for him to be
like just kidding and then snap everyone
right
[Laughter]
i just can't trust this guy yeah like
everyone on the club just jumps off that
i was like oh my god he just snapped but
uh yeah no
it was just really weird seeing him with
friends because he was a very
anti-social person even with his black
order he just had no friends so just
like whoa this is weird he's nice yeah
this is a guy who normally is not here
to make friends but not in this episode
quick recap here young t'challa gets
abducted from wakanda by the ravagers
instead of peter quill leading to this
alternate universe where t'challa is
star-lord and gets along pretty much
with everybody yondu kraglin korath
taserface drax nebula and thanos who has
given up his goal to dust half the
universe but in this place the collector
tennelier tavonne has risen up as a
major threat uh he's running the black
order and his vault on nowhere and from
there this crew steals the embers of
genesis thanks to the help of one howard
the duck t'challa and yondu tag team to
fight against a collector who uses a
cadre of famous mcu weapons and they're
able to overcome him and escape and
return to wakanda meanwhile in the final
scene ego finds adult peter quill
working at a missouri dairy queen but
what did this episode tell us about
thanos's true character his soul if one
conversation with a right taran could
convert him from his genocidal madness
who is this titan exactly and what new
stories does this episode open him up to
in the live action
future of the imps i want to see some
thanos poetry like i want to see slam
poetry from this man really bad open mic
night slam poetry and when the crowd
booze he goes nuts
old macdonald had a farm
you should have gone for the you should
have gone for the you should people just
like head just say head
should have gone for the jugular oh god
um fun announcement here you gotta check
out our most recent latest obsession
shirt it's based on what if over at
newrockstarsmerch.com it is such a cool
design it's limited edition it's seventh
in our latest obsession series and this
is called cosmic witness i love this
thing i can't wait to get mine now
remember our looking black widow design
sold out so you got to grab one of these
while you can there are some other cool
what if inspired merch dropping soon and
we have some great suicide squad and
low-key just general nerd-themed shirts
and hoodies and stickers lots more you
can check out all these great merch
options at neuroxmirch.com but if you
get the cosmic witness shirt you'll get
the added option of writing in a custom
shout out that will appear at the bottom
of the screen these episodes so a couple
people wrote some stuff in we got uh
rita yerby who asked what if mephisto
was at thanos aside instead of ebony ma
hahaha uh yeah i um he was supposed to
be in the infinity gauntlet story ebony
ma was really doing a cosplay of mepisto
if you were to ask me pretty much uh and
i think mepisto is all around us inside
us and with us so
let's see we also have joseph edwards
who said i've got every shirt keep up
the good work still waiting for my shout
out maybe one day
joseph hey
you're the best bro
no seriously you're collecting these
shirts like pokemon thank you you're the
collector you're the collector of uh
you're our chandelier tyvon and we thank
you joseph tanelier to von edwards and
then we have patrick lardy who says what
if mt is just eric's variant no no no my
friend i am mt's variant let's just get
this straight i had no clue if anybody's
anybody's variant i am mt's variant you
know what
i'm proud to have you as my variant my
white variant brother
but your approval isn't necessary i am
who i am and i don't care how you feel
about it this is true be your own
variant all right what was our big
question coming out of episode two well
eric what if thanos actually wasn't
crazy and just needed a friend he didn't
have a friend
that seems to be the real title this
episode
um josh brolin voices thanos in this
what if episode i'm so glad they were
able to get him to come back because
brolin brought so much humanity to the
role in infinity war in end game i can't
say enough good things about what he did
in those movies
and this episode shows us a more
level-headed and relatable side to that
character but if the variance of this
reality was t'challa's abduction in 1988
that would be the x factor that flipped
thanos good somewhere in recent history
now this episode is set 20 years after
1988 which would be the year 2008 that's
not 2014 like the live-action guardians
of the galaxy was this is this is before
that it's it's like kind of right as the
mcu as we knew it was starting um so
these characters are a bit younger in in
their life story uh but it just shows us
how uh you know right when thanos would
be kind of in his early stages of a
stone quest he still would have been a
conqueror at this point now he has given
up that completely so it's a very
limited amount of time that t'challa who
would have been a pretty young kid
talking to thanos would have like
completely changed uh his his whole
mindset now seeing thanos as his
fair-minded team member made me look
back at his history before gaining the
reputation as a mad titan something
that's not really easy to do there's
actually some key takeaways from thanos
story that i don't think we talk enough
about um we know thanos was born on
titan we don't know how long ago we do
know he's an eternal that was born with
a deviant gene he's actually part of the
same family tree athena the eternal but
at some point on titan there was some
catastrophe some environmental collapse
uh seems like it was based on
overpopulation and over consumption they
just kind of ran out of natural
resources but uh loki the series gave us
some clues like miss minutes opening
animation showed a war between it looked
like the titans in the cree
and then in episode two the chrono
monitor screen hinted at some random
sacred timeline bombing target of
october 13 1982 on titan and i'm
wondering if that could have been
titan's apocalyptic event like that
could have been the year it all fell
apart so that from throughout the the
80s going into the mid 90s from the
early 80s onward thanos that's when he
began conquering planets uh kidnapping
children adopting them uh because we
know he already had ebony ma on his team
by the time he conquered uh gamora's
planet um he also
kidnapped annie from the movie annie the
musical that's right
that's right
uh yeah he's not a good guy now we can i
kind of trace when the zahobre people
were killed around 1995. but now in this
alternate timeline we don't see gamora
anywhere in the picture so i think that
means thanos never got to her planet and
that somewhere between when t'challa
came in the picture in 1988 in 1995 that
would be for him between the ages of 8
and 15 this young child
like
christ arguing with the scholars in the
temple was able to change this guy's
mind oh my god him off his warpath i
would have loved to see that like all in
this episode just little young t'challa
be like no no you're doing it all wrong
what are you doing no no no no no no no
we can do it this way we don't have to
keep that sounds like genocide that's so
weird that's right
now
my question as i thought more and more
about this was how uh like thanos still
seems to be making a case for dustin
half of all life he's brag and he's like
it is an efficient idea and they're like
can we change the subject please but the
thing is he's not seriously pursuing it
and i think t'challa just pointed out
that you can reallocate resources across
the galaxy in a better way he's
absolutely right but unlike anyone else
who probably tried to point that out to
thanos t'challa could prove it and not
just with this new gig that they're on
to steal the embers of genesis to feed
billions across the galaxy but uh
t'challa's mindset might be uniquely
wakandan if you think about it because
the tribes of wakanda learned early on
how to share power and resources with
each other really only settle their
differences at warrior falls and then
stay out of all the imperialist madness
of the conflicts of their neighbors on
planet earth so really
their isolation was a gift a rare gift
that way when you pluck t'challa off
earth and bring him into the cosmos he
has been in this kind of
test bubble to show a way it could work
they figured out the answers early on
not just before other nations on earth
but before other planets around the
cosmos and i think this tells us that
thanos might not be a psychopath who was
born without empathy but rather a
sociopath who has learned to detach from
empathy because the universe taught him
not to get too attached not to trust
anyone and really all he needed is one
fresh perspective that he can trust as
uncorrupted untouched by the forces of
the universe free from ulterior motives
t'challa to help him see the light no i
that's really interesting that you bring
that up because like if you remember in
infinity war he says that you're not the
only one cursed with knowledge and like
we have thanos being this person who's
like you know the super smart dude one
of the smartest dudes on titan and like
no one was listened to him like i feel
like he he didn't have anyone on his
intellectual level and then in comes
t'challa who is this person who comes
from this hyper advanced civilization
like and he says like i know a lot of
stuff and like we've been dealing with
like like you said resource allocation
and all this stuff and our culture is
built on efficiency and i think you need
a kind friend and an efficient solution
and someone on your intellectual level
and he was all three of those so like
yeah he just needed a friend and that's
what he did t'challa was the perfect
friend for him he needed a friend from a
different world and like earth is not
only a different world i would say most
of earth is you know operating by the
same uh selfish drives that the rest of
the universe is but wakanda is a totally
different world and they have made
mistakes over the years but they figured
it out and the way that t'challa uh let
me baku tap out at warrior falls and he
was able to forgive him and still work
with his rival i think that's something
you don't normally see across the
universe and even though this t'challa
hadn't gone through that experience
that's still the same kind of values
that the people of wakanda t'chaka
taught him you know this is true but
like also i think a lot of this is
uniquely
uh t'challa and what it it reminds me of
that conversation with um t'chaka in
t'challa where he's like it's hard for a
good man to be king and he's just like
t'challa you got your heart is too big
and like i'm concerned that like your
heart's gonna get in the way of like
you'd be a a good wakandan ruler but
that was t'challa's superpower is being
merciful with like zemo and all that so
like hello yeah zemo is a better example
than baku zemo murdered his dad
for sure
i wouldn't like zebo
but like yeah i think one big deeper
theme of this episode is this debate
between nature and nurture i think uwatu
says that in the opening seconds right
like as you're shaped by the nature of
your world or the nature of you and i i
think you know these movies at least
guardians of the galaxy and i would say
the black panther movie that is kind of
a common theme is that
um your world does shape you you cannot
ignore your influences from around the
world and we are going to end up
uh connecting with each other no one is
on an island you know like we're gonna
we're gonna have to learn to work with
each other uh and guardians of the
galaxy both those movies from james gunn
they argue that
despite how powerful your biological
lineage may be
ultimately you have a choice over who
your family is in your life going
forward and that's what at least
resonated with me from the guardians of
the galaxy movies and that seems to be
the lesson that t'challa learns that
everyone kind of learns is that no
matter what your past is you still have
a second chance to
to make a new choice and uh and to try
to control your own destiny by who you
associate with and and you fall in love
with and who your friends are
exactly like i that's
bang on i was gonna bring this up too so
i'm very glad that you brought it up
first like it's all about
who you associate with like it's it's
that final scene in wakanda with like
thanos and all in all the ravagers
hanging out with like everybody in the
wakanda it just felt like a cool family
cookout scene and i was like good for
you thanos like you have friends and
like people talking to you and like this
makes me feel okay with this universe
that you're not gonna flip out because
you have like a support system so i feel
like it's important for everybody
watching it's gonna have friends if you
are who you surround yourself with a
little uh yeah find your truck yes
pbs for you guys now we know how thanos
loves seasoning food do you think he
tried to season some of the food at the
cookout and they had to be like no no no
no
you don't season our food
would have some like crazy spices that
would probably be fire yeah do you think
thanos under seasons or over seasons his
food you know he i think he's an under
seasoner i don't know he's a baby pinch
that was a heavy fish and that's cute
this is true he's got some big ass dubs
you can't take a small pitch with those
thumbs bro yeah
a pinch you mean a tablespoon
he's like i cannot do a pinch
yeah this is making me want to like have
a thanos cooking show like that would be
so great if marvel just released that on
youtube that's why the universe's
resources are finite thanos because you
keep taking heavy pinches seriously
else is a big dude and he's just eating
more than everybody else who's like i
don't know where the food goes where's
all the food
it's like you're eating it all thanos
you went back for thirds thanos they
call them thirds thanos
for that reason uh well there's a lot
more from this episode we want to talk
about uh but real quick uh thank you to
manscape for sponsoring this episode
attention listeners across the galaxy
all the way from australia to houston do
we have a pube problem if so our friends
at manscape have cleared you for takeoff
with their new fourth generation
lawnmower 4.0 kick your pubes to the
next planet with the performance package
4.0 the orbits and your pants will feel
like you're in zero gravity when you use
the best tools for the job from the
leaders and mail grooming join the two
million men worldwide who trust
manscaped and get your rocket ready for
takeoff by going to manscape.com for 20
off plus free shipping with the code
marvel the lawnmower 4.0 has all kinds
of features like the led light a ceramic
blade a 7000 rpm motor grab yourself a
performance package 4.0 that comes with
a weed whacker ear and nose hair trimmer
some landscape boxers a shed travel bag
and all kinds of other goodies for your
goodies get 20 off and free shipping
with the code marvel at manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with the
code marvel at manscape.com your
spaceballs will thank you also thanks to
helix sleep for sponsoring this show you
don't want to sleep on a mattress
designed for someone else even if it's
an alternate reality version of you that
took the super soldier serum instead of
steve rogers right well super soldiers
still need good sleep helix sleep has a
quiz that matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you they have soft medium
and firm mattresses mattress is great
for cooling you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers i took the quiz and got matched
with the dusk lux helix mattress because
i wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool i sleep
great on my helix mattress way better
than my evil variant twin does
the mattress ships right to your door
for free you never need to go to a
mattress store again they were awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by gq in wired magazine
just go to helixsleep.com inside marvel
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life helix is offering up
to two hundred dollars off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
audience at helix sleep.com inside
marvel that's helix sleep.com inside
marvel for up to 200 off and two free
pillows we also want to thank bluetooth
for sponsoring this show our friends at
bluetooth have a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
a chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost bluetooth is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips it ships right to your
door in a discreet package you sign up
at bluetooth.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you receive your
prescription within days their licensed
medical providers work with you to find
the right ingredient and strength and
blue chew is chewable just like it says
in the name which is great for folks
that don't like swallowing pills so if
you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we've
got a special deal for our audience try
bluetooth free when you use promo code
inside marvel at checkout just pay the
five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code inside marvel
to receive your first month free again
we thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
show all right uh emt let's talk about
the final scene of this episode what if
right peter quill did meet ego before
meeting the ravagers of the guardians of
the galaxy what would have happened what
is this setting up here yeah um it's
setting up pretty much the
impending doom of the universe because
peter quill i feel would be 100 down
with this if if his dad came and he had
no parents like his mom is dead and he
feels stuck in this like small town in
missouri like in this dairy queen he's
totally gonna want to be a god like he's
gonna be like oh yeah let's do this
so like
t'challa being picked up instead of
peter
huge nexus event like that is like ego
is going to use this child as a battery
whether he likes it or not and i feel
like peter's gonna like it but what do
you think is gonna happen yeah i agree
with you mt i think um
like
peter becoming friends with the
guardians of the galaxy i mean his
connection with yondu
was very important to his character
development um and he's a very
impressionable guy like he loves these
people these people these are his family
members and that one kind of
undercurrent for the first guardians of
the galaxy i've talked about before is
it really is about peter's relationship
with his mother and he doesn't fully
understand the deeper meaning of the
awesome mix that she gave him until he's
able to read her note at the end of that
movie after connecting with these other
people and that's why it was so
important when he was reaching out to
gamora when he had the power stone and
he saw his mother there reaching out to
him that was his core dramatic journey
is learning to connect with someone uh
and now he sees the rest this family as
the family that he lost and had he not
had that experience i don't think he
ever would have appreciated the music he
was listening to
um and yeah i i don't think uh ego would
have helped him with that ego probably
would have revealed what he did to
meredith quill um and i think uh peter
would have gotten over that honestly
or he wouldn't have had anyone to save
him at least when ego did that to him
when he hooked him up to his uh
jumper cables
no it's true because like i feel like if
peter
never left like with the act of peter
leaving and running away he was running
away from him dealing with his mother's
death so like if he stayed and like
maybe got some therapy maybe like you
know talk to his grandpa about death and
like you know got over that
he probably wouldn't have cared as much
about his mother as the peer that we get
because peter this right he never deals
with it like you said like that's the
whole journey of him dealing with the
the loss of his mom throughout his life
right and so
if ego's coming along he's gonna be like
yeah like i got a dad this is gonna be
real cool i had no father figure in
yondu so like
let's do it right
yeah
um now mt i wanted to ask you in this
episode we found out that the wakandans
were actually looking for t'challa and
it's when t'challa finds one of the
wakandan fighter jets but it's like a
wakandan spaceship so what if the
wakandans are actually capable of space
travel what contact might they have had
with other planets other civilizations
that we haven't known about yet see that
was the most um exciting part or one of
the most exciting elements of this
episode because yeah like it's wakanda
like of course they're gonna have
spaceships and it's so cool to actually
see one confirmed um in the marvel
cinematic universe and so yeah they
probably definitely
have wanted to go on to the stars for as
their entire culture because their
vibranium meteor came from the stars
like this is a
very cosmic culture so like yeah they
were probably the first ones to invent a
spaceship before the americans did but
i'm very interested to see what contacts
that they've made or if they already
have existing contacts with aliens that
we like what if they're already part of
the uh the jump networks and stuff like
in the
universe and like they they're trained
with these aliens and it helps the
wakandan economy on the low because
obviously they they're good with their
vibranium but like what if they just
wanted to reach out they felt more
comfortable with aliens outside than
like the people around them that would
be really interesting that's what i've
always suspected with like you know i'm
obsessed with hexagons whatever but like
their bubble grid is made out of like
hexagonal shapes which is the same form
of the untn which is how they they
teleport across that's their
transportation super highway system um
now hexagonal shapes is just kind of a
naturally occurring shape that's just
how you fit things to make a tighter
grid i get that um but i just like this
idea that a lot of their technology like
they might have had some help a lot of
it they were able to devise themselves
just by tinkering with vibranium and
vibranium tech but like yeah why i would
love if they had long before roswell or
any other uh
like
known human link with extraterrestrial
societies they're like oh yeah we we we
know about them we know about the creed
we know about scroll like yeah we've
been we've been protecting you guys from
them but i guess you're old enough now
to know
that'd be crazy but like this makes me
think like what if like because we also
we obviously have the fantastic four as
elements that are not around in the mcu
but like wakanda is doing the space race
and we know that fantastic four is all
about going to space i wonder if there's
like a connection there like what if the
fantastic four knew of like i don't know
wakandan space flights like something's
going on over there like they're just
looking at the sky it's like oh this is
weird like
something's coming out of africa but i
don't know whatever um but like i feel
like the fantastic four would be aware
if they did exist in the past but we
don't know that hey maybe uh black
panther wakanda forever will just jump
straight from fast and furious to fast
nine and just go straight to space
straight to space
i i really hope that they do because why
not i think that there's a comic run in
the comics where they actually do go to
space um is it world of wakanda but like
i'm pretty sure that there was a there's
a whole run there so like maybe they're
setting that up mt i wanted to ask you
how did the collector defeat hella he
had her antlers that's true he did how
did they fight or who killed her and who
did he steal this from this is a really
great question because like hello was no
slouch like it's hot i would not attempt
to steal her stuff at all but i was
thinking about it and i was like you
know what this makes sense because
hella's powers do come from asgard so
like let's say that he grabs this before
like after a ragnarok situation asgard
is gone and then hell is like comes out
of her prison like yeah what the
where's my hat where's my home but so
it's like she's just a lady who is the
guy i mean she's not late she's the
goddess of death so like she's but she's
not as powerful as she was in thor
ragnarok because her power source is
gone so i feel like it would be easier
to subdue a hella if you are a collector
who has already started to fill the
power vacuum that thanos left because
like you would have a lot of you know
soldiers and all that stuff to take her
down i mean the collector would have to
already have started collecting some
infinity stones uh he is an elder of the
universe and the in the mcu they haven't
really shown how powerful they are
because they keep doing stunt casting
with like you know benicio del toro jeff
goldblum but like they're they're cosmic
beings with a certain level of power and
might uh i don't really know if they'd
be able to beat hella one-on-one i mean
oh no not definitely not
goddess of death oh no vicious maybe
like like maybe there was some other
kind of battle like valkyrie avenged you
know when hella killed her partner and
then but even then we're talking about
like other what-if scenarios that aren't
related to t'challa i'm trying to think
of like could t'challa have done
something to ripple effect making hello
weaker in this universe
there's too much kindness in this
universe i'm too weak
in a universe where there's more
kindness and diplomacy ella's position
is weakened even though she's already on
a prison planet
well if you think about it i mean
there's less people that are dead now
that t'challa has rea helped thanos
reallocate the resources so maybe
there's a correlation between dead
people and hela's power because she's
the goddess of death so i don't know the
more people who die in the universe the
more powerful she becomes
maybe interesting i like that theory i
feel like we can we can put this in
algorithm form in math form let's get
let's get a whiteboard and write up some
math and figure this out
well we'll see you guys in 18 months
pepe sylvia
um and then uh obviously this episode's
filled with like great marvel easter
eggs again i'm gonna break those down in
the next video you'll see on the channel
but we saw artifacts like
cap shield thor's mule near
at this point in 2008 cap was still
frozen in ice so did the collector just
steal it from the ice
it sounded like korg's arm he ripped off
korg's arm yes i saw that i was like oh
my god he said from a talkative uh
cronin i was like oh what are they
talking of cronin i mean korg is the
only chatty cronin i know of yeah i mean
the the one and through the dark world
wasn't very chatty because he got his
head up yeah i need you tossed up
anybody else yeah well uh i loved this
episode start to finish uh i i'm so glad
they were able to get chadwick boseman
to a record for this and he's gonna be
back in three more episodes uh this
season
and i'm so happy about that uh and uh
we're really looking forward to next
week where we're gonna have a furious
big week episode that's gonna be fun
don't be good it's gonna be good what if
it's so much fun and like yeah this is
so fun show it's been so it was so great
to hear chadwick's voice and like it was
i kind of got a little like a little bit
emotional because like i'm not a huge
i'm not crying but like it was just so
it felt like i was getting a message
from chadwick it's like oh my god like
this is because like he was very much
his character his like not he wasn't
t'challa but like the goodness of
t'challa was who chadwick was and so
like to see t'challa affect the universe
in the way that he does in this episode
almost like this is just chadwick this
is just
chadwick sort of like living on a
different universe
right that's just me rambling no i i
agree i thought that was uh lovely to
see uh and that is it for this episode
of inside marvel mtni gonna be back next
wednesday with our what if episode three
reaction uh stay tuned later today
you'll see uh my breakdown of all the
easter eggs you missed and don't forget
to check out again our great merch
options uh cosmic witness at newark's
merch.com follow me at eavos follow mt
at mastertainment follow new rockstars
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast thank you for watching
and we're close with our favorite moment
of the episode
[Applause]
[Music]
you